you're out in a good man you better be
proud like you better have a certain
Battle of the Year new boot goofing
Pride goes with gimping though yeah
pride comes before it ain't easy as they
say yeah
hey daddies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population
how you doing I'm great thanks for
having me back guys our favorite
foosballer comedian
um second favorite food smaller first
favorite favorite community champion
foosballer why are his parents here in
the Foosball hall of fame
um and dad plays the trumpet so trumpet
trumpet yeah and yo-yo man just a weird
Carney I love it there was no other
option than for you to go into comedy uh
you're like the only person who went
into comedy and your parents are like
thank God you went into something stable
I know
at least you're not like your dad you're
doing something smart all right you're
really figuring this [__] out yeah my
brother went into Finance he was like I
can't be a part of it I can't even talk
that's like a middle finger to both
parents and you I'm going into Finance
yeah it's like enough of this what an
idiot that's his Rebellion
for you yeah you were supposed to start
your own cotton candy stand
well here's the good news Kelsey cook uh
the world's gotten Dumber since the last
time you were on this show yeah it still
keeps going that direction right I was
like we're going through the stories
that our awesome fans send us so now
they send it because this is we've sort
of changed it since the last time we did
this Dan does the story Jay does the
story and I do a story to us it's not
all dance so that's fun so people send
us stories at uh at school Brothers at
Daniel Van Kirk hashtag known people
town and we're like we're going through
the stories and we're like just at the
end of October right now now it's insane
that we have this crazy backlog just
telling us that the world there was a
time where we once said Dan are we going
to have a we got another guest and we're
like are we going to have enough stories
he's like I'm at the end we're never
gonna be at the end
there's just a backlog so it's fantastic
let's jump into a story right now and
then we'll talk about all the awesome
stuff you have going on including good
stand-up stuff so I have the first one
it's off let's go send it by Jake
grooney2 at Jake grooney2 I want him to
change his Twitter handle to grony grony
grony but to spell it like tones
t-o-n-e-e anyway I think Jake caroney
won was taken
if it was I'm gonna be mad by him
because this is his burner account he's
like how dare it because this happens to
some people I don't know if it happens
to you I bet it happens to you you guys
don't have anyone else with your same
name that you've found right so there's
gonna be another Kelsey there's a Jason
sklar yeah there is a Jason score there
is okay what is the other Kelly so she's
a drummer yeah
so if you search my name sometimes she
will pop up there oh we'll do this but
then I've got it sorry if we can do
anything we do whatever he wants say it
go so they um for so my specials coming
out
um in a couple weeks and the production
company had put together this like
surprise poster for me just as like a
congrats this is cool amazing
um but whoever had put my picture on
there like they showed me the poster and
I'm like hmm doesn't that doesn't look
like me I'm like it kind of looks like I
was like I've never taken that picture
before yeah I was going through my mind
I've never taken that picture so I tell
my managers they look at it they're like
no that's definitely not you they go
wait let me look they Google searched my
name they scrolled on images for a while
it was her there's a like a fitness
blogger in Florida named Kelsey cook
that's also blonde no and whoever was in
charge of making that poster just saw
this other blonde well it was right by
it but also I had to tell us all to that
yeah they wanted one that was a side
profile because they made a like a
foosball player out of me so they needed
a side shot and they saw this girl they
just assumed it was me because her name
was also Kelsey cook so there are these
promotional posters out there with like
Kelsey cook the Hustler tour not not
even me
there's a couple other Daniel van Kirk's
there's one uh for like personal people
in my I go by Daniel but uh personal
friends and stuff like that and call me
Dan
um so this guy I met Daniel Van Kirk on
everything yeah but this guy is at Dan
Van Kirk and so he's gotten like quite a
few followers
okay but if you look at the photo it's
if you think that's me we need to meet
so Dan no offense to the guy we just
don't yeah he sits a lot more than I do
that's awesome the best Dan you've been
there have you been to Ted Drewes in St
Louis please tell me are you insane so
tedris is the best we've been together
I've been multiple times
from the vending machine at the airport
so do we told you this story
next across the time Turtle Street on
the same side of the streets Ted Drewes
is like an institution in St Louis is a
little Velvet Freeze which was like a
Baskin Robbins but a local one and I'm
like why in the world would you have a
Velvet Freeze next to the greatest
Frozen costume because they got
sometimes the lines are so long
spillover you get a little Ted Drew's
runoff we call it the Velvet Freeze
run-up so Dan Van Kirk is getting a
little Velvet Freeze runoff
that's what we used to go out when we
were single like in our 20s with like a
really extremely good looking dude of
ours like we'll get the we'll get
everyone's gonna want him but he can
only get one we'll get the runoff
crumbs yeah
there's all like mathematical equation
about that in a beautiful mind where
he's like everybody talks to her I'm
interested in her I'm gonna you should
watch it okay ready let's do it
Jack thank you Jake Gurney guys headline
there are fears [__] man has returned
who you heard my ass man no Slenderman
dude this is Nightmare fuel it is
exactly wearing a zip up mask take
everything you know from Pulp Fiction
and put it on your neighborhood street
late at night what she's just walking
down the street
am I wrong to say I don't know why I'm
pointing at you the [__] is subservient
oh my God so should we be worried that
he's he saw he's waiting to be told what
to do is what you're saying yeah I'm
like he's a sub in search of a home
right he needs somebody to order him
around that's all you get out of here
what are you doing
thank you thank you
it's coming over and over though
smell the glass okay here's the story a
very Sinister man first of all is he
Sinister is he a man do not know if he's
a male or female there's no her man
management didn't know she was the right
Kelsey cook yes look there's another git
man that's not me that's give man with
two ends
a very Sinister man dressed head to toe
and a [__] suit has returned to
terrorize sleepy Somerset Villages this
comes from
metro.co.uk just showing up yatton and
claversham at some point I know that
they're older than us but I think that
like is that like they got bored and
we're just combining other names yeah
and Habersham is definitely the British
Rizzoli in the house but it's also the
British shields in Yarnell like they do
yeah weird sort of robotic robotic mimes
work uh they have been plagued by the
latex clad passed since 2018 who appears
late at night to stalk and terrify the
locals I don't like them despite
arresting two people in connection with
the case police are still yet to
identify or stop the Man known as [__]
man which means they arrested two of
that man's friends but they won't roll
over on get man I mean is this like uh
is this like uh Andy Kaufman what's the
other guys Tony Clifford Tony Clifton
County cliftons are there yeah yeah yeah
but they're saying this isn't the [__]
man so I don't even know what they
arrested the two I think they should
just arrest Alan zweibel just to be sick
just to be safe also this story ensures
that it is definitely not me because of
my severe latex allergy thank you we
rule out I mean in terms of detective
work yeah it's a large portion of the
population I'm out and my claustrophobia
I couldn't handle you couldn't handle
loads sometimes I'll see a woman with
like a choker or a guy with a tight
turtleneck and I'm like just how can you
get that off your neck do you just start
going like what was the old Mitch
Hedberg joke like wearing a turtleneck
is being strangled by a really weird
person yeah that's right uh it now
appears that the shadowy figure has
returned yet again to claim another
victim when we say victim we just mean
scare right also doesn't as far as I can
tell them we'll get into it does nothing
other than staying there yeah or maybe
like a walk towards you of course thank
you but I'm not about to to a story
where like someone got assaulted okay
okay yeah so so in an age where we're
like really upset with people for saying
certain things that are triggering yeah
this is legitimately triggering to have
like a random stranger show up so I
think it's okay to run him over and kill
him I I'm and I'm not in a bad way no
not in a mean way not in a violent way
I mean it is a shadow it's like you
showed up in the neighborhood I'm not a
great driver I'm gonna go over you then
back over you then back over you again
because I don't know what I'm running
over yeah you wouldn't you might like it
right you've got glasses you have that
way about you could be like I just I
didn't have a difficult time seeing
things like [__] men in my neighborhood
it's Kira Elston 19 years old and her
boyfriend were walking home after
getting out of a taxi have the taxi drop
you off thank you
I'm all in favor of uh I have friends uh
friends of mine who are women and
they'll be like I have the Uber drop me
off like three houses from my house just
because I don't need anybody knowing
exactly
fine whatever but if if you're with a
couple and it's a taxi uh this person's
pretty traceable yeah pull up to the
house right also like we get out we want
to walk the last is this like your
parents and you're like at a mall when
you're in seventh grade just drop me off
a corner I'll walk on anyone to see that
we came by taxi well they were walking
home after getting out of a taxi in
yatton around 1am on Sunday when [__]
man emerged from the shadows and started
walking towards them with his arms
outstretched just once give a hug you're
hot well yeah that's a big difference
one of them is very like Lizard King
right and then one and the other is yeah
um we have a photo that'll be thrown up
here I've already shown it to you guys
here's an up close of get man if you
want to see yeah this man's face oh my
God is this in the Marvel Universe
scary yeah okay it's the gimpiverse yeah
exactly uh starts walking towards him
with their arms outstretched she had not
been worrying about someone popping out
of the darkness no one that's normal
day-to-day life she's gonna walk from
the taxi take the several block walk
home I'm not going to worry about it she
didn't worry about it because she was
with her boyfriend but he suddenly shot
at Kira there's a man as they approached
the a roundabout I think he also said do
something about it yeah there's a man
get him by the time we saw him he was
very close and my boyfriend just told me
to run oh
by the way he cares about her have you
guys seen do we have like a height on
this guy well by the positioning next to
the car I would say somewhere around six
feet yeah he's definitely five ten five
it's yeah he's not little he's not like
five four yeah that is so scary have you
ever seen the documentary about the
people who went to go visit the volcano
on Netflix and it goes off
like it erupts while two or like they're
standing there were three tours one was
walking towards the kind of do them in
groups right so as things go the tour
that had just been up to the edge and
taking pictures and stuff they were
about halfway back to the beach and then
the people that just got dropped off
they were about halfway to the rim and
there was a group that had just started
to walk away from the rim when this
volcano exploded people should people
should watch it anyway I'm not going to
give it anyway oh my God however uh no
you know that right away just the first
couple interviews while people are like
covered in like burned scars and you're
like okay you lived right
um
was the volcano satisfied
but I've wondered
in that scenario like if it was the four
of us
[Music]
don't be like oh Daniel like makes you
you come right no no [__] that there's
nothing absolutely have this
conversation while we're sprinting yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I wonder for them like
is do you do you try to run from get man
together or do you just tell your
partner I don't care which direction you
have just get out of here yeah make him
have to decide who to track I think
you've got it I like that yeah I think
you gotta run together because I think
two people can beat up give man well
then don't run beat up get mad
your advice is not running man if you're
fighting games because you're gonna then
be tired when get man walks to you
um Kira said that the encounter was the
most terrifying experience of my life
it's a quote adding another quote I've
got the image in my head of him walking
towards me and staring yeah well to be
fair you can't really I mean he could
have been looking over there yeah for
sure he also could have had a Wandering
eye yeah you don't know that either and
he could be a she I dread to think what
would have happened if I had been on my
own I I can't of course yeah I'm still
really shaken up by it as he walked
towards them he stopped and stood with
his legs shoulder width apart and his
arms out like he was proud she said like
he wanted me to remember it well that
now she's pushing too much to it yeah I
felt like he had a broken heart but she
also she keeps this no I made that up
she didn't say that she does keep
assigning qualities and he looked like
he was out of change his dad left when
he was five yeah for sure wait I think
he looked like he was wondering why he
couldn't trust people yeah or like she's
also the type of person in the
relationship with the guy her boyfriend
like at a dinner party be like so he
really hates swimming and he's like I
don't really hate swimming I mean he's
just got this water thing but they
eventually don't really have a water
when get man gets caught he's like first
of all I'm not that proud but I would
say also if you're out in a git man you
better be proud I know like you better
have a certain problem
Pride goes with gimping though
experience isn't the first time the
mysterious pervert has been is what they
wrote has been cited in the area yet
authorities are still no closer to
uncovering his true identity how many
times do you guys think [__] man has
been reportedly uh like had a report of
him scaring somebody or being seen on
the side of Man sightings since 2018
what do you think since 2018. 2018
five-year Spanish I will say that the
big headline is he's returned inferring
he there was a he did a while or this
isn't it sabbatical yeah you know what
this is just for me sometimes I need to
study I gotta I can't this giving is so
hard
I am gonna go with
um 14. 14 okay Randy 35 times [__] man
has been 62 times 62 times yeah
terrorizing they said since 2018 getman
has been has scared people or reported
16 times
so good oh yeah you were great you Vibe
on these Gift Stores yeah a police
search turned up nothing after Sunday's
incident and the suspect left no Trace
at the scene of course he didn't his
gloves he's in a condom yeah he's full
dextered out there's no nothing's
getting in or out of there
um uh where was I hear his father Steve
Elston Steve Austin Yates uh appealed
for help on Facebook
Steve Alton Yates Stephen Elton Yates is
a long time for this podcast a great
author and a wonderful father amazing
very nice guy shows in New York brings
pizzas sends me wine on my birthday I
love Stephen the sweetest guy ever so
the fact that this guy's name is Steve
and we can make a Stephen Elston Yates
joke is perfect yeah incredible
um so anyway back to Steve Austin Yates
uh that's Kira's father he appealed for
help on Facebook
well I don't know someone
where do I go I don't know who to talk
to I know I gotta sell a couch and I
gotta I have a wisconsin-esque accent I
live in England I live in England what
do I do I told my mother early in
Facebook I go this is how I need you to
think of everything you ever write
you're in a gym
full of everyone you've ever known some
of most of whom you've forgotten are in
the gym
whatever you say you're talking to all
of them if you need everybody you're on
a microphone in front of the gym yes no
a headset like you're teaching in a
robust for sure whatever it is have you
not have you ever explored this on stage
this is very such a great idea really
funny so if you're like well I guess
Mondays suck
expect someone that you haven't talked
to in 10 years to be like well oh yeah
well my dog died
this is a fully formed [__]
squat rack oh my God word economy
everything
oh that's very nice but yeah I really
wanted her to like I'm like this is how
you need to think of it yeah Dad it's
like it's like uh I hate Mondays and
then someone like from behind like where
the dumbbells are is like you can blame
the Liberals for that
sometimes it's not even going to be what
you wanted to talk about somebody's
gonna be like you should have used a
comma and then you're gonna be like I
that doesn't have anything to do so
right the dad on Facebook who's like
yeah everybody I need help here like you
better want it it's a gamble yes you
could say Gamble and people are gonna be
like he's not that scary and like wait
Jeff you're here your old history
teacher who doesn't believe in the
vaccine's about to pipe it yet
you've always been a [__] Steve Elson
like what dude I'm trying to help my
daughter my old wrestling coach damn uh
he went on Facebook to find the man that
he said he is quote on the hunt for him
this is a total Dad I'm off oh yeah yeah
go Steve Austin he added last night my
daughter and I'll just do it her
daughter and her boyfriend were
approached by a [__] man around 1am at
the top of claverham road where yeah
where it meets getting High Street which
is also perfect American he needs to
give directions yes not past the blue
house over by the roundabout you know
where that dog barks right around there
there's a lot of NorthEast Southwest
involved and it just doesn't happen you
need to make but stay close to the curb
because people like to put their trash
bins out if you see a white fence on
your left you're facing the wrong way
that's not where get man is
then he wrote do not park in the
roundabout he's actually kind of smart
he then went on to say could you PM me
private message I always go DM
could you PM me if you have any
suspicions as to who he is also could
people in that area check their doorbell
footage please and I'm like hey that's a
bar that's okay A little detective
what's dead here Bobby's should be doing
in England Kira was absolutely terrified
she contacted the police who didn't even
come around to take a statement so she
said quote and we'll get out of here on
this I'll be hunt I'll be on the hunt
for the [__] man myself she will Kira
has Kira's had enough I love that it's
the most terrible continuation
yes I'm gonna hunt his ass down oh
that's Story number one please I love it
down in the books when we come back from
the break room I think it's Randy I
think it is we're going to tell you uh
how you can watch Kelsey Cook's new
special which based on when this comes
out May already be close
we'll figure it out we'll give all the
dates and all that stuff and if it's
after the fact she'll tell you how you
can watch it if it's before the fact
we'll do all of that is coming up she's
a fantastic stand-up if you haven't seen
her live this is your opportunity to
consume the great stuff we'll be back
after this break
out hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get into Kelsey's special and
what she can do uh wanna did you say
what she can do what you can do to watch
it before we get into Kelsey's special
and what all the things she could be
like juggling
she can make fun of her dad read on
stage
I saw her walk in here on her own one
time she wrote a unicycle so look all
the things she can do all the things
we'll get into it in a second but first
let's talk about Daniel please let the
folks know where people can see I mean
everyone see the show yeah every
Wednesday Irene two and I have a show at
the lyric Comedy Hour uh that's at 7 30
on Wednesday nights and then would you
rather comedy uh Comics do their sets
and at some point also get asked a
random or choose to they can do it if
they want but it's a great way for
people like me to create new material
and stuff you get a would you rather
question on stage I love it I have to
talk about that yeah and then
um I'll be at moon tower I'm doing uh
stand up shows there a living wake
and a live dumb people live dumb people
town we'll talk about the guests we'll
figure out who will do that that's the
21st 22nd and 23rd of April everything's
at danielvankirk.com uh everything for
us is at superscars.com but just so you
know Lawrenceburg Indiana we're doing
the Lawrenceburg Event Center nice on
March 4th that's a huge room we'd love
to see anyone in the Cincinnati
Louisville upper Indiana I think
Indianapolis is close uh but come see us
because we really love this hour of
stand up that we're doing so that's
happening on March 4th end of March we
just booked uh Phoenix stand up live I
love that room so much the 30th very big
room also big room but we'd love to see
everyone in our Phoenix people come out
for that
then uh moon tower as Dan said we're
going to be doing dumb people time we're
doing tag it which we love that have you
done that she did that show that was one
of my favorite shows we did at moon
tower remember we did that smaller oh
yes it was Velveeta room is that right
no no no different venue but I remember
it it's so fun Comics do their sets and
then we write tags for the comments
during their set events
walked away with great tags it's really
wonderful by the way we're talking The
Comedy Store about potentially doing a
regular tag it there which would be
really fun so it would be so good maybe
the works we'll let you guys know about
that then we're in Minneapolis we're
coming to Minnesota on May 18th 19th
20th yeah or 19th 20th 21st so we'll be
there and uh working on some maybe a cup
coming back up to Alaska a couple times
in the fall with some friends so we'll
sort of let you guys know about that
again still haven't heard about the
nosebleeds yet fingers crossed we get to
do another season to that right now as
of this recording hopefully this
recording yeah all right so let's talk
about the special how can people watch
it when does it come out are you proud
of it are you happy how are you feeling
yeah so it will come out on March 9th on
YouTube It's called The Hustler so it
will be available everywhere on that day
on YouTube if you want to get it early
it will be available for purchase on my
website kelseycook.com on Tuesday
February 28th so exactly two weeks from
when we're recording it but I don't do
we know when this is coming out we don't
but maybe we can adjust so that it uh
we'll figure it out yeah
no pressure no this could drop on the
28th so if that's the case that might
actually work so hopefully fingers
crossed will adjust yeah um so I
recorded it at Comedy Works in Denver
nice that's an okay Club the best
downtown downtown yeah amazing you know
tier one of the tier one clubs it's
really yeah so good it's unbelievable I
did my album there a few years back and
it's just whatever crowds are so good
and that room in particular it's got the
low ceiling and it just feels like
you're being comedy Heaven you got to go
downstairs to go to comedy
comedy on state the seller I mean what a
great just what a great Vibe and great
energy and did you feel that as you were
recording yes so leading up to it was
kind of strange because
it was the Stanley Cup finals on the
exact same night
and the Denver Avalanche were in it so
that's something that of course you
can't prepare for I mean you pick the
date of your time in advance right and
then we find out
I think it was like a week or two before
and all of a sudden I'm seeing all these
messages pop up like in comments like
I've got tickets for Kelsey cook special
taping for sale over and I was like no
no no no no
saving tickets are everybody's giving
them up because they wanted to either go
to the game or just set it they would
have rather sat at home and watched
again
massive thing so uh we we did end up
being able to get a bunch of people in
there and pack it out but the first show
we did two tapings that night the first
show was fantastic such a great crowd
that is like basically what most of it
came from right but then we had the
second show which you also hope is gonna
be great just to have if you want to
pull other things sure and what had
happened was
um the Avalanche game had let out by
that point and so we got a bunch of
people who were in a complete blackout
oh my God that were just because the
stadium was like right right yeah right
by the club like the blocks within the
yeah so people are just hammered walking
around the streets like what else can we
do so there you see that there's the car
woman is doing her special
Jersey yeah yeah so we had two women who
were I mean like three rows back like
five women right up front yeah and
within the first five minutes of my set
just talking to me just like loud saying
stuff to me saying stuff to each other
and so I stopped the table I was like
hey I'm just telling you guys right now
you know usually if this was a different
show I'd talk to you we do something
else but like you guys either have to
focus or get the [__] to go wow like you
got it what they did and I'm looking at
them and you can just see like nobody's
help right look at her eyes over here
one eyes over here and so I try to get
back into it immediately start talking
again I'm like all right we like they
gotta go so everything comes to a
grinding oh my God this is this is
insane I mean yeah people don't know
that like that does not happening it
doesn't help either yeah so everything
comes to a halt they are so drunk that
they're it took them like a solid like
five to seven minutes just to get their
stuff and leave because they're dropping
stuff they're like baby deer wobbly
I could I was like trying to see where
they were they were still had this long
walk and I said to them I was like a
glacial Pace with you two and one of
them turned around and like gave me
double birds and flipped me off and I
was like this is such a weird feeling I
would have never expected this to be
part of the specialty so of course none
of that's in the special
that should be some of the extras yeah I
know buy it on the 28th make this your
conversation with these drunk idiots I
know oh my God all right well check it
out
the Hustler yeah YouTube on on March 9th
available for purchase purchase it this
is a way to support
that's how you support a comic it's very
easy to do it gives yourself
entertainment yeah I would love it and
I'm sure it's a great special because
I've been watching clips of your stand
up and I just love where you're at with
it right now so I know it's going to be
great all right shall we jump into it
let's do a story too okay this one is
sent in by our good friend Carlene
mcdermon at chibi Carlene she's amazing
uh this story is for all of us who fly
constantly and I would put it to you
throughout the entire time what would
you do I'm going to keep asking you what
would you do if you were sitting next to
this person are you guys American people
no no you jump around we're the dumbest
you never comedians ever we didn't pick
an airline because we have to split the
money on every single gig and even an
extra 200 300 on our flights hurts us so
we go with the cheapest flight on the
cheapest airline and in the end we
[__] ourselves because we don't get to
bump up to first class we don't get to
go to the lounge and we travel as much
as anyone it's the dumbest thing ever
yeah you guys feel like you should just
start now though yeah we should I mean I
think Delta would be it but they don't
fly direct to Chicago that's my only
reason
but you know you just get the AmEx
platinum card and then you have launches
what's your airline Delta and I've got
the AmEx the reserve and the Platinum
yeah I just I did everything for adult
Dynamics to try to bump up as many parts
and we'll be right back more frequent
well no I asked because we're about to
dig it I'm a Southwest guy literally
yeah what a Savage they give you shorts
the West guy yeah they give you short I
love it okay Dan writes comedy for them
are you ready for the headlines here the
headline here business class passenger
okay we're talking about a different a
business class passenger is like the
drunk girl at your show's like it's my
birthday yeah we don't give a [__] it's
her birthday shut up business class
passenger booted off plane after warning
cabin crew not to look at her for blank
amount of time and we're gonna get into
it I don't want to give it away don't
care me for a blank amount of time so
have you guys experienced air rage on
any flight recently is what I'm asking a
couple years since I've released but I
got I got a buddy named Nick who's a gay
agent for Southwest in uh of course
Midway and the stories he tells me yeah
it is
Chicago guys
[Music]
give me everything he's like I walked
this dude off this [__] flight I go
hey here's what's gonna happen they're
gonna kick everybody off this [__]
flight and the cops are gonna come here
and drag your [__] ass out damn dude
I could leave real quick and the guy he
goes he looked at me and he's like let's
do this brother he goes like okay we
step out into a jet way yeah and there's
no cameras out there I go let's go let's
go baby let's go she goes I got more
things to say cause you told me you were
done talking
it's got like a Clint Eastwood man
Nick's a badass guy and so he's like
he's just very he's just he has this
sort of thing so they're like Vin Diesel
things but real life like where he looks
you and he's like it's not gonna go it's
not gonna go the way you want it to go
you're not gonna I'm just telling you
right now it's not gonna go the way you
want it to go Dan no no here's my
questions can they so we we've met a lot
of MMA we've met UFC folks nicest people
nice people but never like fight but
they don't they don't want to fight but
they like fighting so like Forrest
Griffin's like I liked fighting that's
why I got into MMA so I think they don't
want to fight in the real world because
they're like I don't want to do that I
don't want to get sued or whatever right
I think they should be the guys to come
on to the plane and just be like all
right so I have 14 professional MMA
fights under my belt let me just show
you me in action and here's here's
footage of me in a thing you want to
step off the plane now we I'll take you
out and not mean not imposing because
they'll become Nick would never actually
find it he's like the nicest dude but he
just has an ability to go we're not
doing this yeah you know by looking at
them you aren't going to do that I love
it the calmer someone is the scarier
they are right okay
freaking [__] man probably very calm
anyway air rage is at an all-time high
and this latest incident is no exception
Danielle di Matos remember her she's now
tomato sounds like a brand of Olives
that are too spicy too spicy did you get
the tomatoes well I'm not putting them
in the salad are you kidding me it's
gonna ruin this whole salad
you gotta put it on the side yeah you
got any type of Jordan Air
all right so she's a software company
concierge she had plans to fly from
Sydney Australia to Honolulu Hawaii for
work however a series of Moody moments
led to her getting kicked off the
Hawaiian Airlines flights so now
Hawaiian Airlines they have a great new
campaign where have you seen this like I
don't know if it's because I'm watching
the I watched the bear or the first
season of that but I watch anybody who's
a chef and I'm like I feel like I know
them now there's a Hawaiian Airlines
thing where it's like there's this like
woman who's a chef and she's working
really hard and then all of a sudden
like the walls of the kitchen open up
and like they hand someone walks in and
puts a lay on her and she walks out of
the kitchen and onto the flight and then
it lands it's like nice Hawaiian
Airlines Hospitality I assume Hawaiian
Airlines is calm you've gone Hawaiian
Airlines you better be [__] [__]
right yeah you know what I mean it's
like people are going to a nice
destination according to the Daily Mail
travel travel troubles began upon
boarding when the cabin crew directed
The we're gonna get her age in a minute
um woman to her economy seat
prompting the accused to verbally abuse
staff members the cabin crew then
realized they had made a mistake so they
were like here we go to your seat right
here as dematos booked a business class
ticket so this is what Jesus you already
started with a mistake on my party I
know people like that who you know the
second you make a tiny mistake they feel
disrespected yeah you do what's his name
what's her name uh shortly after the
camera okay this the camera crew
realized they made a mistake as demattos
booked a business class ticket and
directed her to the correct seat where
she calmed down so you as a flight
attendant you're like okay they go back
to the little drink cart in the front
they're like all right that [__] has
calmed down a little bit sure keep an
eye on her but she calmed out yeah
shortly after the cab okay crew took an
alcoholic drink prematurely this is so
they just so she wasn't finished she
wasn't done okay which caused the
accused to become verbally abusive
towards staff members according to
documents tendered in the Downing Center
local course there's documents about it
oh yeah the accused mood changed quickly
and she was then apologetic and
remorseful after this see this is where
you got all the stages of being drunk
too this is I feel like there's drinking
with medication involved yes that might
be it you might have crossed the
personality I'm mad I'm fine
yeah you're the best yeah I love you so
much
you're my friend I don't like him yeah
you're my yeah to bring this person into
the I don't like that but we don't we
don't like him all right come here come
here tell him I don't like we don't like
him no I'm not with you on this let's
dance it wasn't long before her mood
shifted yet again no [__] she was fine
then it shifted again to me this is like
emotional turbulence in turbulence
turbulence in b class as the plane
started a taxi towards the runway
damanos began staring down the crew
member who had previously taken her
drink wait we haven't taken off no this
all happened in the seating oh so she
had a drink she or she got a drink as
well as they're sitting here when
they're sitting while they're waiting
for the plane to get loaded up yeah or
almost finished it and they're like we
need to collect this possible right
she's performing the in-flight just as
the woman's performing the in-flight
instructions she starts staring her down
now again Dan if you're sitting that
Kelsey you're sitting next to this woman
is just like giving her the freaking eye
yeah that's all it took you don't take a
drink away from this woman and no reason
at all the stare down left the
stewardess feeling intimidated but
according to the statement of the facts
this is where things get interesting
as a result of these interactions the
cabin crew advised the captain of the
accused Behavior the captain formed the
view that the accused erratic and
disorderly Behavior presented a risk to
the safety well it's only going to get
worse right like right yeah this is
where you are whoever the captain and he
or she was probably like get her off we
we can't this is where it started how
long of a flight are we talking here
because it sounds like a pretty cool
Honolulu right no no but also you're
over water there's no like yes we gotta
make sure everybody's in an okay I'm
guessing that's about a seven hours
Captain decided it was best to return
the aircraft to the terminal and offload
to matters so you're on the flight you
know it's going to be a long flight and
now you're returning back because a
crazy lady I would allow the passengers
to ever going to get a shot in just one
one just pop in the back of the head not
hard but just yeah like a snack like a
dummy like you dummy like a bad kid like
yeah we're just a low-key like hit the
shoulder as you walk by yeah hit her
hard enough you've got the big backpack
yes definitely swing that one over yeah
take the window I don't want to hurt
anybody but I want him to go wait whoa
hey did he break her nose like by
mistake with like the well that's a
harder another with a backpack we just
want to rough around here like that's
like mirror bleeding like let's go back
Jason rolls Jada's mouth
it goes too hard no no it's the
selfishness of both people in these two
stories the fact that you're carrying
out something that has that you think
has no effect on anyone else Danielle
we're going to Hawaii yeah let's just
calm down [__] be cool [__] be cool
who we're flying to Pittsburgh or
anywhere in Florida you could see some
sort of like oh who know you could be
going you know we're going to Hawaii
this is where you put it on Pittsburgh
but like it's not the relaxation
destination I'm not rooting for roofies
but if I was like a thing I'd be like
just knock her out like give her a roof
give her like give her three Xanax on
the borderline of like an overdose but
enough to just go back a drink we could
pump our stomach later this is where you
bring Samuel Jackson on the plane he's
like [__] beagle [__] be cool it's
that's it say what again seven or eight
damn seven or eight I'm not saying
stomach pump but I'm saying like seven
hours for like enough hours to make her
family because so another female cabinet
approached her to explain what was going
on and you can imagine that was not well
received no during this she placed her
hand on the accused shoulder to calmer
the stewardess placed her hand on the
shoulder which caused the accused to act
aggressively towards the crew members of
the statement said you don't put your
hands on a person who's like locked in a
death stare with somebody else
De Santos time on the plane lasted all
of how many minutes her
um
starts before she was kicked off you got
to figure she got on at least one first
or second group right and they're more
making it to the runway so that means
everybody boarded and they were
theoretically about to take off
I'm going to say 22 minutes okay Jay
what do you think 41 minutes
46 minutes one of you is one minute off
or down I'm gonna go Michael Jordan 23
what do you think 40. 40 what do you
think
45. okay I feel I feel that feels good
one of you is exactly right oh there we
go Santa's time on the plane lasted all
of 45 minutes
before Hawaiian Airlines airport
operation staff came on board to order
Mr mattos to leave the aircraft Pawn
refusal to vacate the plane they called
airport police for help she said no like
I wanted airport police look I uh these
guys look at her if you are if you
followed me enough you know how I feel
about current state of affairs however
there are plenty of police officers that
at least get to like do something good
right right where they're like oh we're
we're here to help whatever it is right
right if you're an airport police it's
never good there's never any positive
yes maybe everyone's while you're
getting to help find a lost kid you
never get it though hat off of the wing
that's not gonna happen there's no part
of it that is ever like there's no
positive oh what do you need us for oh
wonderful we'll be right there and I'm
sure they will be right there but it's
never fun someone baked us a cake that
we're all going to eat so Australian
Federal Police federal police officers
came to take damadus away she was
belligerent but eventually walked off
the plan on our own accord so they got
her to walk off on her own accord
demento's action delayed the flight for
more than how long
this is where I'm like well she's on for
45 minutes how long did it delay the
flight because you know it could then go
on for so much longer yeah you lose your
place in line then you got to give me
the tool even once they get her off they
still have to do a report and they have
to get her back off underneath find her
no let that [__] go down
you you now go through the system yeah
we're not going to deny your bag this
trip so we're talking about how
we're talking about how much time from
when she got kicked off to when they
took it
how long did she delete we're supposed
to take off at three they took off I'm
gonna say 4 30. an hour and a half what
do you think three hours what do you
think
three hours is nice 40 minutes 40
minutes okay they it caused the flight
to be late for more than an hour just an
hour okay so right again
upon deliration she was arrested and
charged Tomatoes pled guilty to one
count of behaving in an offensive or
disorderly manner I didn't even know
that was the thing
acting safety when she appeared before
the magistrate this is such a great name
for a magistrate Theo
Savard
savardis
t-h-e-o-t-s-a-v-d-a-r-i-d-i-s sheesh
Theo correct Savard
on to the next round savartavus
convicted tomatoes and find her how much
money
how much would she find for this fifteen
hundred dollars fifteen hundred what do
you think uh I want to say five thousand
dollars what do you think yeah
um and that's not enough
Seven Grand Seven Grand all right get
your answers in townies she was fined
six hundred dollars that's it not enough
there's an increase it's like a stress
so we're gonna get out of here on this
oh this is crazy how old is crazy crazy
crazy dematus I'm gonna go 42 42 years
old yes knowing what we know about her
she's in b class she got her feathers
ruffled as well it seems to be by
herself so this is her like Eat Pray
Love trip maybe yeah I don't know yeah
she wants to hike a waterfall drink pray
and go into a drink
[Laughter]
um I feel like that would have been my
guess I'm gonna say 44. damn that's the
dumb people down version of Eat Pray
Love just drink pray
I'm going to say she's 36. okay
one of you is exactly right now do you
want to guess who's exactly right do you
want to stay with you well I feel like
it's in the 40s so I'm gonna go 40. I'm
sticking with myself 48 you said 42 and
you said 44 44 and are you guys okay get
your answers in counties because
Drea Demento no that's Danielle Andrea
De Mateo Danielle di Matos software
company concierge who had plans to go
from Sydney Australia to Honolulu for
work yeah this is a work trip now
and got thrown out the plane after 45
minutes and keeping it delayed for an
hour and completely upsetting everybody
too
is 36 years
[Applause]
no I'm sure she's not nobody's
Constantino that is crazy and you would
be so mad and that would be your Daniel
I know you that would be your opening 10
minutes uh of your set whatever you did
would be honest at the blue note that
night right let's talk about that and
have a fully formed bit and have a full
Dan would have a fully formed bit ready
to go Jay give us a little taste of what
we're gonna hear in segment three uh an
interesting way to chase away a
Jehovah's Witness great I love it okay
we're always looking for those new ways
all you have to do is shut the door I
know okay I'm going to remind you again
Kelsey Cook's special The Hustler is
available for purchase on our website on
February 28th if this drops on the 28th
go get it right now sure get in between
this break pick it up and then you can
watch it after it's out wide on YouTube
I bet you could outline on YouTube on
Marshall if you're watching this on
YouTube just hop over and watch that too
but I say purchase it there we go we'll
be right back with more dumb people town
right after this
hey guys welcome back to the show let's
do Story number three all right here's
the headline naked woman chases
Jehovah's Witness off her porch down the
street yelling quote succumb to my devil
vagina magic okay
okay the whole story I don't know if I
need to do the story
[Laughter]
oh mad guy I always hear Mad Libs that's
a Mad Lib I thought I heard mad Gap and
that also could be describing her yeah
yeah for sure this was sent in by David
P Fournier at dp40a2 nice this is the
first time I think David Forney thank
you David uh this is from Fillmore
California Brandy Williams do you know
where film was where we shot Bubble Boy
that's right so not far from here not
far from here it's like up by Maps kind
of see me you kind of take off and go up
around Randy Williams don't want Brandy
Billy Brandy
girl a little like this name doesn't
shock me that like when your name is
alcohol you're gonna have problems right
for anyway you know my daughter cognac I
went to high school with a brandy and
she wouldn't let me into her party
McGee uh the nicest Brandy we ever met
the coolest Brandy we ever met Brandi
Chastain from the U.S Olympic women's
soccer team the coolest yeah she's
holding up the average of Brandon she uh
she's and Brandy who didn't live in her
party we were ready to say Brandy
Carlisle yeah maybe I'd take it back
she's she said there's some high
averages but then there's some wild it's
like Sherry you got your rotaris but
then you also got like yeah okay
as soon as I said it and we drove by
another golf court that was going a
different way and this is the only piece
of the conversation we heard and one guy
sang to another guy one guy first of all
he's wearing cut off jean shorts and no
shirt I was drinking a beer drinking a
Bud Light beer yeah
or anybody in St Louis he says he says
this is the only part of this
conversation we heard and we repeated
this for decades he goes well that's
Sherry Faria
does all you need to know Cherry what
did she do again set the carnival on
fire I'm like I get Sherry in that one
comment I get it she got drunk and fell
asleep at work that's Brandy yeah the
two women so probably a Sherry
succumb to my demon vagina yeah death
magic my devil vagina magic uh she was
taken to Ventura County jail after an
altercation welcome to Jehovah's
Witnesses Ms Williams was seen running
naked after the two young men on
bicycles who were going door to door I
spread the message of Christ in her
neighborhood she saw the men about three
houses away from hers and decided right
then and there to strip off her closings
so you only know that if she says that
or someone's in the living room
give these guys memory they will not
soon forget I give these guys a piece of
her vagina I guess this is what the
sheriff said you didn't need to go that
hard like just answer the door with one
tit out and don't acknowledge it because
they'll be too awkward to like say
anything God I wish I had the [__]
audacity and just be like you guys know
something to drink maybe some milk and
then don't even Ms Williams thought it
would be funny to answer the door in the
nude
[Music]
they're familiar with folks they they
are familiar with folks being nude but
what Miss Williams did next went a
little too far the men Luke and John
sorry uh of course we're used to people
being rude right slamming doors and even
yelling them but for a naked woman to
greet them at the door that was quite a
shock neither neither one had seen a
woman naked before do we have to put do
we need to put that in there well they
kept saying it probably and they didn't
quite know how to respond damn I never
understood being mean
I've done things where I was like Hey
guys at some point in your life you will
probably and hopefully question all this
and if that day comes remember this
address and I'll answer any questions
yeah I'll help you get back because they
need to go that to me is a little like
and I if they never question it and they
live nice lives where they only treat
people great and they treat themselves
like go for it I don't care
yes but I do want you to know if someday
questions creep in come back knock on
this tour then and we'll have a
different conversation I'll say neither
one had seen a woman naked but here's my
tip they didn't know how to respond come
on not to mention the strange erotic
Sensations they were feeling for the
first time as well
it's way too much quite obvious that
their message was not going to be heard
this person's taking some Liberties
exactly uh that it was time to move on
to the next one when the men returned to
their bikes Brandi wasn't done yelling
or trying to get it under their skin
with all of her skin a nude Brandy
started speaking of her vagina and the
devil's magic and content take a good
look at my
uh succumb to my devil vagina magic this
got the attention of the pair of men
that got the attention
a second is there
magic going
they began to fear what may happen next
and began to Pedal away so they were
cool with this naked woman well they say
they get that a lot yeah all right lady
okay Brandi took off running after them
but she did not make it too far as the
neighbors had already informed police of
an altercation involving their neighbor
and the two young men she was
apprehended without incident after
having their statements taken when the
men were free to go spread the word of
God how funny would it be if as she's
walking back she sees one of her
neighbors hey Dave listen can you just
take that recycling can back for sure
I need a cat sitter
this is her all the time not even just
for them you're on a date with with her
with Brandy and she's like well my [__]
is devil magic
so full of devil magic so if you guys
want to see her I don't have her age or
anything Brandy hey guys uh hey uh wow
that's exactly what I pictured here this
is what you would think she was that's
exactly what I pictured here but you can
see even in that mugshot confidence
confidence yeah right hey uh Jim Patty
I'm gonna be out of town for the next
couple weeks if any packages come
floating on my door with your arms
behind your back
well you guys did it you caught the
Brandy [__] man
look at her she looks like uh like it's
a sugar it's a smirk yeah she's got a
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do what else what were my options is her
look on her face she's got a devil [__]
magic make hair attitude about that
she's got a devil [__] on my mind I
believe that was backstory there you go
Story number these were great I loved it
and I always love goofing around with
you thank you Hustler The Hustler comes
out on your website yes kelseycook.com
and my tour dates are on there too I'll
be in Cincinnati Kearney Minneapolis uh
San Francisco Denver and Chicago all
coming up in the next month or two great
girls love it go see her she's wonderful
and if you're drunk and you're coming
from my hockey game don't yeah but
everybody else you can go see it and uh
guys oh [__] we gotta get back to work
stick around make a sound there's more
than people town
[Music]